[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX PAPPAS: Good afternoon.
Thank you for taking time out
of your busy days inventing
amazing, world-changing
stuff here are Google.
I'm Max Pappas.
I'm in town from the
Washington, D.C. office
where I'm on the
public policy team.
There, I manage Google's work
with think tanks and policy
organizations like the
American Enterprise Institute,
AEI for short, which
is one of the oldest
and most influential
and well-respected
think tanks in the country.
So today I'm thrilled to bring
to Google AEI's president, Dr.
Arthur C. Brooks.
Arthur Brooks has been
president of AEI since 2009,
where he's also the
Beth and Ravenel Curry
scholar and free enterprise.
Before joining AEI,
Dr. Brooks, who
has a PhD and an
MPhil from RAND,
was a professor at Syracuse,
where he taught economics
and social entrepreneurship.
It's also worth noting
that before pursuing
his work in public
policy, Arthur
spent 12 years as a
classical musician
in the United States and Spain.
Dr. Brooks is also a
regular contributor
to "The New York Times,"
best-selling author
of 11 books.
And his books include topics
from the role of government
to economic opportunity,
happiness, and the morality
of free enterprise.
And his latest book is "The
New York Times" bestseller,
"The Conservative Heart: How
to Build a Fair, Happier,
and More Prosperous America."
He's also published dozens
of academic journal articles.
And he wrote the textbook,
"Social Entrepreneurship."
Today he's going to speak about
how to lead a startup life.
With that, please join me
in giving a warm welcome
to Dr. Arthur C. Brooks.
ARTHUR BROOKS: Thank you, Max.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks a lot.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
It's great to be here at Google.
I'm always-- I've
been looking forward
to this for a long time.
Good to see you.
And good to see folks who
are on a live stream--
I actually can't see
you, but you can see me.
And I know that there
are a couple hundred
folks that are watching us.
Also later on YouTube,
I'm looking forward
to having some interaction
with these people where
people are watching us later.
We have a big
commitment to the work
that we do in our
YouTube channel at AEI.
We have a pretty large-- for
think tank-- a pretty large
following in our
YouTube channel.
So if you like what
you're seeing here
and what we talk
about here, please go
subscribe to our
YouTube channel at AEI.
As you heard from Max, I'm
the president of the American
Enterprise Institute.
That's a think tank
in Washington, D.C.
It's been around since 1938.
We do work on public policy.
But what we really try to do
in all our work, all 250 of us
in Washington, is to think
about old problems in new ways.
I mean, as you know
since you're at Google,
you know that when you're
trying to solve an engineering
problem, trying to make
a big breakthrough,
the way to not solve a problem
that you've had for a long time
is to simply think harder
in the old ways about it.
You have to find a new
way to think about it.
That's why you go out
and walk around sometimes
and you come back and
you find oh, I can
think about that in a new way.
Now, we don't have
engineering problems
per se in public policy.
But we have old problems
that need new solutions.
We have problems in policy.
We have problems in politics.
And everybody seems to think
that we don't have solutions
to these problems.
I want to talk to you
in just the next half
hour about how to think
in a new way about policy
and how to think in a
new way about politics.
Now what am I not going to do?
I'm not going to tell you how
you should feel politically.
Everybody has their own
opinions on politics,
so I'm not going to tell you
what I think about politics.
I'm not going to
tell you what you
should think about politics.
I'm going to talk about thinking
differently about old problems.
Now when we talk about
thinking differently,
I want you to think
of a time in your life
where you had an experience
of suddenly having
an epiphany of thinking
in a different way
about an old problem, even
in your personal life,
and how it changed things.
I was trying to think about
a good example of that.
And I did think of one.
And I'll give you an example
just from my ordinary life,
not from my work life at all,
of an inflection in my thinking.
It was recently, relatively
recently, a year or so ago.
One of my kids--
I have three teenage kids,
not to tell you my problems.
And one of them--
I was having a parent-teacher
conference for one
of my teenage kids.
And it wasn't going
very well, which
is pretty normal for teenagers.
If you don't have kids,
you probably will.
And it was a grades problem.
And so my wife and I, we left.
And we were in the car
and we weren't talking.
And it was uncomfortable
and we were kind of unhappy.
And my wife said, we're
thinking about this problem
in the wrong way.
We need to think
about this problem
in a totally different way.
And I was like, I'm all ears.
How should we think about it?
She said at least we
know he's not cheating.
So OK, why do I bring that up?
That is a different
way of thinking.
And in that spirit,
I want to find out
how the problems that we're
having in policy toward poverty
in America can be seen as
an opportunity for renewal
for our country.
And then I want
to talk about how
politics, which is really bitter
and polarized and divided,
is an opportunity for us
actually to come together.
So this is subversive and
pretty radical thinking.
It's not how to make
problems go away.
It's how to think
in a new way so
that the problems that
we have are actually
opportunities for the country.
That's my job.
So let's start with what's
actually tearing the country
apart with respect to policy.
It's the haves and have nots.
It's the polarization
with respect
to income and opportunity.
It's the fact that income
and inequality, we believe,
is higher than it's
been in generations.
How do we solve
that in a way that
helps us have greater
solidarity as a country?
I was thinking about
this and trying
to actually figure
out a way to describe
or to come up with a
new kind of thinking.
And I was listening to
a friend of mine who was
giving a lecture about poverty.
A friend of mine-- he's the
assistant Archbishop in Los
Angeles--
Catholic Archbishop
in Los Angeles.
And he was actually
quoting his great mentor
from the Archdiocese of
Chicago, a great cardinal,
a great Catholic cardinal
named Francis George.
And this visionary cardinal was
talking to his richest donors
about poverty and
basically telling them
why they should give
their money to support
poor people in Chicago.
And here's what he said.
He said the poor need you
to pull them out of poverty.
And you need the poor
to keep you out of hell.
It's like, gutsy move, right,
with your riches donors.
I'm not going to use that to
fundraise for my organization,
by the way.
But why is that an epiphany?
Why does that actually lead to
a breakthrough, breakthrough
thinking?
Because I was thinking
about it later.
And I thought, do we need
poor people in our society?
I mean, I understand we
want to help poor people
and understand that
we want to have
some sort of a sense of
charity toward poor people.
I got it morally.
But do we actually need them?
And the answer to
that question--
here's how I want you to
think about it for yourself.
Here's the thought experiment
that answers that question.
There are a lot of poor
people right in our midst
in Mountain View, California
right now, not very far away
from us.
I mean, further away
certainly than 20 years ago,
because of the way that the
real estate market has worked.
But if you go even as
far away as San Jose,
lots of people who are really
at the margins of society
and they're poor.
If all of the poor people
within 50 miles of where
we are right now--
really poor, the bottom
of the socioeconomic spectrum--
if they suddenly disappeared
just like that, would you know?
How long would it
take you to know that?
Would you-- if you're
downtown, would you say,
oh wow, fewer homeless people.
Or if you're looking
like a policy wonk
like I am at the data,
would you say well,
policing and welfare services
have just gotten cheaper.
I don't know, maybe.
But would you know
it for your life?
Would you know it
with your friendships?
in your social life?
I bet you wouldn't,
not for a long time.
Why is that a problem?
Because it's weird historically.
It's an unusual thing in
America that we actually
wouldn't miss poor people.
Why?
Because poor people are
who we are as a country.
This is a country that was
literally built by poor people.
This is a country
that was built largely
by immigrants who were poor.
It's an amazing thing.
I don't have to remind you
that the quintessential, sort
of the iconic image of
immigration in this country
is Ellis Island and the
Statue of Liberty, right?
Well, the Statue of Liberty
has a poem at its base by--
it's a pretty bad poem actually.
You had to memorize it when you
were in high school if you went
to high school in the states,
which if you're an immigrant
you didn't--
by Emma Lazarus.
But there's one line in it.
This is the Statue of
Liberty and the first thing
that immigrants
would see starting
in the late 19th century.
The poem says "give
me your poor."
It didn't say give
me your rich people.
Don't give me your high-skilled
engineering immigrants,
although that's good.
Give me your poor.
Why?
Because this is a
country that had
to be built by the refuse
of other countries,
of the outsiders
from other countries.
We were supposed to be a magnet
for people from other countries
who were basically
ambitious riffraff.
Here's the amazing thing.
If you're born in
the United States,
you descend from
ambitious riffraff.
And you're proud of it it's the
only country in the world where
we're proud of the fact
that our ancestors were poor
and we tell the stories.
Like, oh yeah, my
great grandfather--
he came and got nothing.
He had nothing.
I mean, he was like living
on the bus or something.
And then my grandfather--
he went to high school.
And my dad, he went to
college for the fir--
this is the story of every
American family, right?
But it starts off not with my
great grandfather was a Duke.
That's a European story, man.
We're actually
kind of embarrassed
if your great grandfather
was really, really rich
and you're not.
Something happened
along the way, right?
So OK, what does this mean?
This is in the DNA
of this country.
And yet we've divorced
ourselves from any relationship
with poor people, even
though almost literally,
at least in the
intergenerational sense,
they are us.
So what happened?
We can't fix that unless we--
and we can't figure
out how to make
poor people necessary
in our lives
unless we figure
out what went wrong,
or at least what happened.
So sometime between when
my parents were kids
and all of their friends were
poor and when my kids are kids,
we've become a society that's
divided on socioeconomic lines.
And we don't know
each other anymore.
When did that happen?
I think I actually know the date
when that started to happen,
believe it or not.
I mean, this is sort of
artificial and bear with me.
I think it was April, believe
it or not, April 24, 1964.
That's really, really precise.
What happened on that day?
The answer was the
United States--
the President of
the United States
declared the war on poverty,
which is a great thing.
That day was actually a photo op
when President Lyndon Johnson--
he went to this little
town in Kentucky
in Martin County,
Kentucky, a place
called Inez, which is
really super hard up.
It was the heart
of coal country,
but the mines had closed.
And there had been mills
and they had closed.
And people were out of work.
And it was poor.
So he went there with
a bunch of reporters.
He was a master, by the
way, of the photo op.
We think that President
Obama and President Trump are
really great with the press.
Huh-uh.
Lyndon Johnson.
He was the master.
And so he went with
a bunch of writers
from Time Magazine
and photographers
from Life magazine--
rest in peace.
And they went to this
little town in Kentucky.
And they went up--
here's the beauty of it
Johnson takes the reporters
to a random guy's house.
It's a guy named Tom Fletcher.
He's sitting on his porch--
tar paper shack with like a
bunch of kids up on the porch.
And he walks up and
says, tell me your story.
His name's Tom Fletcher.
So Tom Fletcher--
it's a terrible tale.
He's a 38-year-old
father of eight
who has a first grade education.
He hasn't worked in years.
And his kids are malnourished.
And he has no hope
of finding a job.
OK, that's what Johnson
was looking for,
because he comes down off the
porch and he's walking away.
And he says to the reporters--
this is the beauty of it.
He's so great.
He said, today I declare
a war on poverty.
And our goal is total victory.
And you would have cheered,
because he was basically
saying look, third-world
poverty is right here.
It's in America.
Just look.
But there's a solution.
We're declaring war
and we're going to win.
He gets back to
Washington, D.C. And he
puts a general in charge
of the war on poverty,
a great American patriot
named Sargent Shriver, who
also created the Peace Corps.
And when he was asked
what the goal was,
Sargent Shriver said our
goal is dignity, not doles.
I don't care what
your politics are.
You're totally down
with that, I know it.
Not making people
dependent, making people
have a sense of
their own dignity.
That's really what
we're all about.
Isn't that what we want?
OK.
So the question is
how did it turn out.
That word dignity I want
you to have in your head,
because what is the essence
of a life of dignity?
It's not being helped.
It's not being a charity case.
It's earning your own success.
It's having meaning and purpose.
It's to be needed.
Like I said, I've got a
house full of teenage kids.
They don't always like me.
But they need me.
And that's a source
of dignity for me.
That's a source of meaning
and purpose in my life.
And the reason that after
I leave California I'm
going back to
Maryland where I live.
And I'm looking forward
to that, because I
want to go where I'm needed.
It's really important to me.
It's important to you, too.
It's important to all of us.
Now what happens in
society when something
has gotten so
blinkered in the way
that we take care
of poverty that we
tell generations of people that
they're not necessary anymore?
We're going to help you.
But we don't need you.
That's actually what's
happening today.
The data are overwhelming.
When I was a kid, about
7% of men-- able-bodied,
working age men--
were out of the workforce.
And I grew up in Seattle in
a working class neighborhood
in Seattle.
And we would see kind of
guys, certain guys who
would not work.
And it would be a pity.
And you'd say that's not right.
So what is it today?
It's closer to 18%
of working age,
able-bodied men aren't
in the workforce.
That's what happens
when we do help,
but we don't think
seriously about how to make
people needed in our society.
That's what we need to
do in public policy.
The solution is not how
to help people more.
It's how to need people
more in public policy.
If you want to know what
the dysfunction comes
from when we don't need people,
look at the data on this.
This is really incredible.
There's a paper--
an academic paper
in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences
last year, published by two
economists at Princeton.
It's a paper about demography.
And most of it is good news.
Every group, every age group,
every demographic group
in society has been getting
richer for 100 years,
has been dying later, and
had better public health
for 100 years.
Here's the bad news.
One group has turned
against that trend.
From 1999 until
today, one group has
been dying younger with
greater health pathologies
than they were before.
That group are white men 45 to
54 without a college education.
They are dying younger and
younger for three reasons.
Number one is a 46% increase
in cirrhosis of the liver,
a 78% increase in suicide, and
a 323% increase in drug overdose
deaths.
These are guys my age, but
without a college education.
That's an epidemic.
It's a problem of despair,
which is the inverse of dignity.
And the lack of dignity
comes from whole generations
of people who are not needed.
OK, so what's the
solution to all this?
To think differently.
If you want to solve
the problems of poverty
and you want to solve
them permanently
and you want to
solve them in a way
that you would
deserve to be treated,
don't think about better
ways to help poor people.
Think about better ways
to need poor people.
I'm at Google right now.
You solve problems.
You solve hard problems.
If you're a social activist,
if you want permanent solutions
to greater justice, think
about how that one gets solved.
Don't think about
just how we can
make people with high
educations and high spending
capability more
productive-- the top 10%
of the income distribution.
I'm already productive.
And so are you.
I don't need to be
any more productive.
I'm maxed out, man.
Think about how we can
bring greater productivity
to the bottom third of the
population socioeconomically.
What are we doing for
them to bring them
into full citizenship?
Because when we make
people more productive,
they are needed more.
Stop thinking about poor
people as charity cases.
Start thinking of poor people
as potentially productive
human assets, the
same way that we
talk about rich people's kids.
How do we do that?
I don't know.
But that's what I'm
thinking about these days.
And the way to think differently
is to move from help to need.
Now, before I move
on, it's easy--
I'm talking a little
too much about them.
But let's think about you,
too, about how much it's
important for you to be needed.
And let's put a real
face on it, about what
happens to people's lives
when they're needed.
I do a lot of work
as president of AEI.
When we're doing work
in a particular area,
I like to talk to the
people that we're affecting.
Looking at a data set
is not sufficient.
So fairly recently I was
at a homeless shelter
in New York City that
has amazing outcomes,
because all of their
incomes are based on work.
They take these guys.
And they've been in prison
and they've been drug addicted
and they're homeless and they've
abandoned their families.
And it's just like the worst
situation, the situation
that you can't really help.
And they put them to work
sweeping the streets.
And then they have
minimum wage jobs.
And they learn skills.
And there are amazing outcomes.
So people don't go back
to prison very often.
And they don't go back and
live on the streets very often.
So I want to know what
their success is all about.
I'm meeting these guys.
And I meet this guy who--
he went to prison when he was
18 for murder, of all things.
And it was a weird thing.
He had smoked a lot of dope
when he was in junior high
and then went to harder drugs.
And he was running
with a bad crowd.
And one thing led to another.
And there was a robbery
and somebody got killed.
And he went to prison.
He gets out.
By the grace of
God, 22 years later
he's on parole when he's 40.
And he's basically
starting his life at 40.
And I meet him.
I see him nine
months after he's out
of prison and off the streets.
And he's working in this thing.
He sweeps the streets
for three months.
And then he gets a job at
an exterminator agency--
what fancy people call a
dead-end job, but is not.
It's a job, just
like all of our jobs.
And I ask him how
his life is going.
And he says I'll show you.
And he takes out his iPhone,
which is pretty cool.
But that's not the
secret to happiness.
But what he's showing me is
he's got an email from his boss.
And here's what it says.
It says emergency bed bug
job, East 65th Street.
I need you now.
I said so what?
He said look at it again.
He just said I need you.
That is the first time
in my life anybody
has said those words to me.
That, my friends, is
the source of meaning.
You want to make people--
you want to bring them
into full citizenship,
you want to give
them happier lives
you, want to permanently solve
the moral problems of poverty,
make people needed.
That's principle number one.
Now let's think about-- from
policies, let's go to politics.
So let's get a
little rougher here.
Max and I live in Washington.
Think of it that Max
lives in Washington so you
don't have to here at Google.
And you should be very
thankful to Max for doing that.
It's fine.
But it's probably not where most
of you would choose to live,
particularly if you're not
obsessed with politics.
It's very tough.
And it's particularly
tough right now
because of the polarization.
You can't go any
place or do anything
where you're not having
a political conversation.
And frankly, it's exhausting.
And in many cases,
it's unpleasant.
And you're watching
yourself all the time.
Why?
Because we're in
a period of almost
unprecedented polarization.
The left is the left and
the right is the right.
And they don't overlap.
And we feel like we've
got nothing in common.
Don't believe it?
Go on social media,
which I know you all do.
You find that it's almost as
if we inhabit different planets
or we have different
DNA or something,
because there's so much
separation between these two
groups of people.
What's the solution
that could actually
bring us back together,
bring us really
back together as Americans?
That's what I want to
talk about right now.
Now, if you're
watching the debates
that we had in the last
presidential campaign,
you watched Hillary
Clinton and Donald
Trump talking to each
other, you know that it's
unbelievably unpleasant.
I was talking to my
14-year-old daughter.
I remember having this
conversation where I said,
don't forget the things
that those people are
saying to each other--
that's not consistent
with our values.
So I actually had
to apologize as
if I were sitting with
her watching "Breaking
Bad" or something.
It's a presidential
debate, for Pete's sake.
We should be proud of this,
of the working of democracy.
Instead I'm apologizing
for the fact
that neither one of these
people is saying something
that reflects my values.
They're saying terrible
things to each other,
treating each other
with contempt.
Now first of all, you
have to ask yourself,
how did we get into
this situation?
Because it's deeply suboptimal
from a practical standpoint.
You all know, because
you're normal people walking
the earth, that you will never
insult anybody into agreement.
It's never happened
in human history.
An impossible.
Like listen you moron, I'm
going to refute all your facts.
And somebody is going to go
hey, you know, he's right.
I am a moron.
I never thought of it that way.
It's never happened.
Never going to happen, right?
It's very impractical to argue
the way that we're arguing,
because politics are supposed
to be the art of persuasion.
Nobody's persuaded.
But also there's kind of
a moral problem with it.
I do a lot of these talks for
very ideological audiences,
sometimes very left-wing
audiences, sometimes
very right-wing audiences.
So yesterday I was
at Cal-Berkeley,
which is not known as a stalwart
right-wing audience, of course.
But sometimes I am in these
very conservative crowds.
Two years ago,
before the election,
I was doing a talk for
a Tea Party Patriots
rally in New Hampshire.
I do like 175 talks a year, so
I get a lot of opportunities
to share ideas with people.
But this one was really
arch conservative people--
three-cornered hats
and the whole thing.
And I was making a point.
And by the way, the people
were talking about tax policy.
And I agree mostly.
I agree.
I'm a free enterprise warrior.
I want more
capitalism, because I
want to lift up
people who are poor
and I want to make
them needed, which
means you need the right
kind of policies, to be sure.
But I'm down with this
stuff, really a lot.
This is a friendly crowd.
And I'm talking to them.
And I made one point.
I was talking about
political divisiveness.
And I was talking about
political progressives.
And here's a point that I made.
I said my friends, I
want you to remember
that political
progressives are not stupid
and they're not evil.
And I meant that.
And this lady raises her hand.
And she says actually, I
think they're stupid and evil.
And you know what I
thought at that moment?
AUDIENCE: Did she
actually say that?
ARTHUR BROOKS: Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
I mean, it's not
mixed company, right?
This is people who think alike.
And people are empowered
when they're in-- right?
And here's what I was
thinking at this moment.
This was actually a
breakthrough moment for me,
because it was funny.
I mean, she was trying to
be-- it was funny, right?
But I told you I
grew up in Seattle.
I grew up in a liberal
family in Seattle,
which is totally
redundant because they're
all liberal families
in Seattle, right?
And when she said that,
you know what I thought?
She's talking about my family.
And I took it personally.
It doesn't matter that I
actually probably agree
with a lot of her politics.
I love my family.
It's like they're not
super political or anything
like that.
But they're not Tea Party
Patriots, for Pete's sake.
And when somebody
says progressives
are stupid and evil, they're
talking about my mom and dad.
And I resent that actually.
Now, why was that a
breakthrough for me?
Because actually,
let me ask you.
Here's why.
Look, we're all from
different places.
We all have different
backgrounds.
views on politics.
How many of you love
somebody with whom
you disagree politically?
Like, 100%.
Come on.
It's 100%.
We all do.
If you want to know the secret
to political reconciliation,
if you want more solidarity,
you have a responsibility
to stand up to
people on your side
because they're
insulting your family.
That's how you do it.
That's courage.
And that's the
secret of the problem
that we're trying to
solve in this country.
Banding together with
people with whom you agree,
effectively insulting
people with whom
you disagree but have a personal
relationship is not courageous.
It's not even loyal.
So how do we do that?
How do we do that?
How can I-- I can't
just say do that,
because I have to
be more specific.
I've got to give you some
tips on how to get that done,
because you know what?
You're going to have an
opportunity to do this
within the next 24 hours.
And you're going
to think of this.
So let's make it a little
more specific, a little more
practical.
When you think about the problem
that we have today in politics,
I mentioned a word a little
bit earlier that's contempt.
People often say that there's a
lot of anger in politics today.
It's actually not
an anger problem.
It's a contempt problem
in politics today.
Contempt is defined by
social psychologists
as the conviction of the utter
worthlessness of another human
being.
And that's how Hillary
Clinton and Donald
Trump talk to each other.
That's how their supporters
talk to each other.
That's how people in the
press talk to each other.
Look at Twitter.
It's the contempt machine, where
people talk to each other--
anonymously, by the way, because
when people are not anonymous,
they tend to behave better.
Never be anonymous.
If you want to have a
happy life and treat
other people with more
respect, always give your name.
Your handle should have your
real name in it, in my view.
Again, advice-- unsolicited
advice, I might add.
So how do we see contempt
manifest all the time?
It's how people treat each
other in the political sphere as
utterly worthless.
Now why does that matter?
Anger-- simple anger resolves
in reconciliation, just
naturally dissipates.
Contempt never resolves.
When somebody treats you
with contempt, blows you up--
what an idiot.
That's the dumbest
thing I've ever heard--
you never quite forget it.
Remember when you were in a
class in college and somebody
treated you with contempt
and just burned you, right?
It gets worse, by the way.
There's a guy at
University of Washington.
His name is John Gottman.
He's a social psychologist.
I've never met him.
But he's kind of an
intellectual hero of mine,
because he's dedicated his
life to marital reconciliation.
He has a laboratory where he
brings couples together that
are on the brink of divorce.
And he has all of the
best scientific techniques
for getting people
to not divorce.
That's a huge deal.
There's no society in
history that's successful
that has not been
based on the idea
of successful, intact families.
So anybody who keeps families
intact, in my view, is a hero.
And that's what this guy does.
I don't even know him.
I'm sure he's a great guy
because of what he's doing.
And so John Gottman--
he has this experiment
where he takes couples
that are quarreling, maybe
going to get divorced,
and he puts them
in front of the camera.
And they have an argument about
what they're disagreeing about,
whether it's how you raise
the kids or about money
or whatever.
And then he'll watch the tape.
His assistants will film it.
He'll watch the tape later.
And he'll turn
the sound to zero.
He's just looking at this thing.
And he can predict
with 94% accuracy
which couples will be
divorced within five years
just by looking for five
seconds at the tape.
So what's he looking at?
Max is married, so
he wants to know
what's he looking at, right?
What's he looking at?
And the answer is signs
of contempt, most notably
eye rolling.
Teenage kids-- I see like
eye rolling all day long.
They practically fall
backwards in their seats,
they roll their
eyes so hard, right?
That's fine.
But you know when it really bugs
you is when your coworker does
it or somebody with whom
you're having a discussion who
owes you respect or at
least some civility does it
and worst of all when
somebody you love does it.
It's like a physical
attack practically.
It's bad for you.
It's bad when you do it.
But I bet you can kind of
catch yourself from now on.
You're never going to be
the same after this talk,
let me tell you.
You're going to go into your
next political discussion
and you're going to say, oh,
I'm acting with contempt, right?
And I'm hurting somebody.
And I'm going to
have a permanent foe
as a result of this,
unless I fix it,
because that's the truth.
Contempt is the problem.
What's the solution?
OK, now to begin with,
it's not your fault.
If you treat people
with contempt,
it's not your fault
because that's the habit.
That's what you see even from
the President of the United
States is contempt and all
of the social media and all
the press.
It's all contempt all the time.
You can be forgiven for behaving
like everybody else, right?
It still doesn't make it
OK or acceptable to others.
But I understand why it happens.
It's a habit.
So how do you break a habit?
Any kind of habit?
For years I made my living
in [INAUDIBLE] as a musician.
I was a French horn player.
I played in the Barcelona
Symphony for a long time.
And like everybody in
the Barcelona symphony,
I was a smoker.
It's so gross, so terrible.
It's such a bad habit.
It made my mother sad.
So I decided I had
to quit, right?
But I didn't-- I mean,
how do you quit smoking?
The answer is don't
just quit smoking.
You got to do something
instead of smoking.
That's the way the
brain works, by the way.
There's a lot of good
neuroscience on habits.
And habits can
only be broken when
you put something in
place of the bad habit,
so I took up drinking.
No, kidding.
So the habit of
contempt, therefore,
can only be broken if you do
something instead of contempt.
So catch yourself--
you're going to be
in a conversation on
social media or in person,
at the dinner table or with
a friend or with a colleague
or even with a stranger.
And before you do
something contemptuous,
you're going have to do
something else instead of it.
What do you do when
you feel contempt?
This was a research
project for me, by the way,
a few months ago.
It's like so I got to
be practical about it.
I want to break
this habit myself.
And I want to help
you break this habit.
So what do we do instead?
What's the equivalent of when
you want a cigarette going
for a walk around the block?
What do you do?
I asked everybody.
I asked social psychologists.
I asked brain scientists.
I asked people that
I really respect.
But here's the best answer
that I got from the person
that I really respect.
One of the people I respect most
on the Earth is the Dalai Lama.
It's a weird truth that I have
a relationship with the Dalai
Lama, because he does stuff
with my organization, with AEI.
He's come to AEI
a bunch of times.
I interview him.
We made a documentary
film together.
We've written for "The
New York Times" together.
It's the weirdest, most kind of
counter-intuitive thing ever.
But I just love him
because he's helpful
and he's a good
teacher and he's kind.
And so I'm always just all ears.
Well, a few months
ago, we were in India
in Dharamshala, which is
in the Himalayan foothills
where he has his monastery.
And we were making a film
and doing some conferences
together.
And I was thinking about this
problem, contempt, contempt.
What do I do when
I feel content?
So I asked him.
I said, Your Holiness, when
I feel contempt, what should
I do?
And he said practice
warmheartedness.
And I said you
got anything else?
Because, you know, that
sounds sort of soft.
But then I thought about it.
I thought about the
man I was talking to.
And for those of
you who don't know,
the Dalai Lama is the spiritual
leader of the Tibetan Buddhist
people.
He has been the
Dalai Lama, or he
has been identified as the
Dalai Lama since he was a kid.
And he's been the leader of
the Tibetan Buddhist people
for many years, for decades.
Well, something happened
to him fundamentally.
He was exiled from Tibet
when he was 17 years
old by the Chinese government.
And he took his people into--
or the leaders of the Tibetan
people-- into exile in India.
Now, he's poor.
The Tibetans are poor.
It's 6 million people
in this vast territory.
So what happens?
Gone, forgotten.
It's done.
But no, because the Dalai Lama
has used, over the last seven
decades, his position as
the world's most respected
religious leader to treat the
contempt of the people who
exiled him with warmheartedness.
And in so doing, he's actually
created a world-wide following.
What does he say basically?
He has this old saying.
The Dalai Lama says
that I defeat my enemies
when I make them my
friends, because they're no
longer my enemies, of course.
He told me he actually
starts every day praying
for the Chinese leaders,
not that they'll
give him his homeland
back, but they'll
live happy and good lives.
That, my friends,
is warmheartedness.
I don't know if I'm
strong enough for that.
But when I thought that-- here's
the point I'm trying to make--
it sounds like warmheartedness
is sort of weak, right?
It's actually for
tough, strong people.
Contempt is for people
with no discipline.
Contempt is for people who
have bad habits, people
who have mental tics, people
who can't control themselves.
That's what contempt is for.
Warmheartedness is for
disciplined people.
It's for people who
can control themselves.
Contempt is for sissies.
Warmheartedness is
for strong people.
So question, how strong are you?
Next time you have
this opportunity,
how are you going to use it?
OK, let me be more
specific, because I'm still
not being helpful enough.
How can you turn contempt
to warmheartedness
in your own life?
I asked that question, too.
Give me some tips,
Your Holiness.
I need some lessons here.
He said-- it was
very interesting.
He said think of a time when
you have done this by accident,
when you've turned a
conversation around
and you made an
enemy your friend.
Remember that.
Remember that feeling.
Remember that occasion.
And that will be your teacher.
So I went back to my little
room where I was sleeping.
And I thought about it.
And I did have an
experience where I did this.
And I want to tell you about
it, because it actually-- now
I remember it all the time.
And it's changed my life.
I mean, I just--
I don't write angry
tweets, because here's
what I think about.
And again, you know
my position where
people are pretty
contemptuous, because we're
in the middle of public policy
and we're Washington, D.C.
And sometimes there's
controversy and all that.
What do I think about?
I think about an experience
that I had 11 years ago.
So before I came to AEI--
I've been president for
almost 10 years of AEI.
Before that, for a decade
I was a college professor.
I taught most of that time
at Syracuse University
at the Maxwell School
of Public Affairs, which
is a wonderful public
affairs school.
And I had a good thing going.
I had a happy life.
I was working in
professorial obscurity,
writing my books and
articles and teaching
my graduate students.
And life was sweet,
I'm telling you.
And then a weird
thing happened to me.
I wrote a book right after
I became a full professor,
so I had tenure.
And I was completely protected
from ever being fired.
I could have killed
a guy and not
gotten fired, because I
would have had tenure, right?
And so I thought, how
am I going to use this?
Well, I'm going to
write a book that
maybe is more controversial.
So I wrote a book about charity.
I wrote a book about
philanthropy, which
was my main area of research.
But I asked the question, who
actually gives to charity?
Who thinks they give
to charity but don't?
And I looked at the
difference between poor people
and rich people and religious
people and secular people.
And I also looked
at the difference
between conservatives
and liberals.
And that, of course, was going
to be really controversial.
And the book comes out.
And it hits the news cycle
in just the right way.
And my life changed,
because as sometimes happens
to obscure college
professors, my book
started selling hundreds
of copies a day.
And my life just
changed overnight.
I went from obscure college
professor to being on the radio
and on the television
just within days.
It was crazy, because I was
getting all this feedback
from people.
I was not ready for this, right?
I mean, my wife was like you've
got to get a better haircut.
You're on TV all the time.
It was stuff like that.
It was like-- it was different
times for me, obviously.
11 years-- a lot has
happened in 11 years.
And here's the weirdest part.
I was getting letters and
mostly e-mails from people
I'd never met, because when
you have a book that's really
selling a lot, people
will write to you
and tell you their opinions
even though they don't know you.
I love your book, I hate
your book, whatever.
So I get an email from a guy two
weeks after the book comes out.
I'm just sitting at my
desk, my office in Syracuse.
And an email pops up-- ding.
Dear Professor Brooks, you
are a right wing fraud.
And that's not a great way to
start an email, by the way.
That's not very inviting.
But I keep reading,
because I'm game.
I'm a good sport.
And the first thing I
notice is this email
is like 5,000 words long.
It's going to take me 20
minutes to read this email.
But I'm reading through it.
I'm well into it.
Here's the second
thing I notice.
Every single point in my book
is being refuted by this guy.
It's a guy from Texas, right?
I mean, in the most
vitriolic terms, in detail--
the insults are
detailed, like you
know the columns in table 3.1?
They're reversed, you moron.
You know, stuff like that
where it's like, wow.
And every piece of data, every
conclusion, every paragraph,
detail.
And you know what I was
thinking the whole time
I was reading this email?
Thought kept coming to
me over and over again.
He read my book!
Because nobody
ever read my books.
I couldn't believe this
guy had read my book.
And I was just filled
with gratitude,
because it had never
happened to me before.
I mean, it was like
my life was changing.
And it was because people
were reading my stuff.
So I thought to
myself, you know,
I think I'm going to tell him
what's on my heart right now.
So I wrote back to him.
Dear so-and-so, I know
you think I'm terrible
and you think my
book is terrible.
But it took me two years
to write that thing.
And I put my whole
heart into it.
And you read every word.
I am so grateful
to you for that.
Thank you.
Send.
And then I waited,
because I was thinking
I wonder if this guy will
actually write back to me,
right?
And sure enough, 15
minutes later, ding.
I'm working on a data set
or something and I look up.
And this e-mail has come in.
And I open it up.
Dear Professor Brooks,
next time you're
in Dallas, if you want to get
some dinner, give me a call.
I defeat my enemies when I
make them my friends, remember?
This guy went from
wanting me dead to wanting
to buy me dinner in the
matter of just like that,
almost the blink of an eye.
Why?
Because I accidentally
treated him
with warmheartedness in
response to his contempt.
It was a case study of
the Dalai Lama's principal
that I learned only
some years later.
OK now, that's what I think of.
And you have something
that you've done, too.
I'm not so virtuous.
I was just being honest at
this one particular moment,
a little bit vulnerable.
And look what happened.
You can think of
these things, too.
That's your case study.
That's your teacher.
That's your guide.
That's what you
need to think of.
What was the key
ingredient in that thing
that just happened, by the way?
Let me hone in a
little bit more on it.
It was gratitude.
Gratitude is the
contempt killer.
If you can remember to be
grateful for the things
that you really should be
grateful for, because think
of all that we should
be grateful for.
Think where we are.
It's a beautiful day.
We're in Mountain View.
You're working at Google.
There's a lot to
be grateful for.
Remembering gratitude
will kill contempt.
There's a wonderful
principle of this
in this-- there's a book
that your parents probably
read called "How to Win Friends
and Influence People" by Dale
Carnegie.
Go get it.
It was a big best
seller in the '30s.
Go get it.
It's a beautiful book.
It sounds like it's how to
bend people to your will,
but it's not.
It's actually a guide to
courageous, ethical living
where you treat
others with respect.
Very beautiful book.
And in the book,
Dale Carnegie was
this early
self-improvement writer.
And he's traveling
around America
to find the most successful
people and find their secrets.
And so he gets to New York City.
And he goes to Broadway to see a
magician named Howard Thurston.
Howard Thurston was the most
famous magician of his age.
He was a celebrated guy.
For 40 years he'd been doing the
same tricks night after night
after night on Broadway.
And so Andrew--
Dale, not Andrew Carnegie.
Dale Carnegie goes to see
Howard Thurston to find out
why he's so great.
Now the tricks are all
really conventional.
It's rabbits out of hats and
card tricks and all this stuff.
But he figured out that
what was really going on
was Howard Thurston's
relationship to his audience.
He would tell a joke
and people would laugh
and he would laugh, too.
And he was super into it
like it was the first night.
Now, he'd been doing this for
40 years, same tricks, 40 years.
That was the secret.
First night, same
spirit every night.
So he goes back to Howard
Thurston's dressing room
afterwards.
Mr. Thurston, I understand
now why you're so popular.
You made it look
like the first night.
How did you do that?
He said, oh it's very simple.
Every night before I go out,
I'm in my dressing room,
I say the same thing to myself.
I am truly grateful
for the people
in those seats who make it
possible for me to do something
that I love.
That's pretty important.
That's now what I say, because
I get to do that for a living,
too.
I get to do something
that I love.
I get to talk to
you about truth,
truth that brings
solidarity and brotherhood
and love to other people.
This is my job.
What an amazing thing.
I'm so grateful to you
that I get to do it.
That gratitude, of
course, kills any contempt
when you display it while
you're talking to somebody
else about politics.
Why should you?
Why should you be
grateful at that moment?
Because you're living
in a free country where
because you have a
difference of opinion,
nobody's going to come and
knock on your door at night
and haul you off.
That is historically
unprecedented.
God bless America, that
even if we display contempt,
we're not going to
get arrested for it.
That's something that we
should be grateful for.
Furthermore, if you join me in
believing that we should not
be living in a one-party
state, that by construction
means you feel grateful to
people who disagree with you,
who are not from your party.
You should be grateful.
And you should
express that gratitude
for people who are
on the other side
in the competition of ideas.
Remember that and
prosper from that.
OK, sum it up.
I've tried to give
you two new ideas.
I don't care what
your politics are.
my politics are.
If you want to have policies
that help people more,
don't think about helping.
Think about needing them.
If you want to put
that into practice
to try to solve political
polarization and contempt,
remember that you actually need
people with whom you disagree.
That's how we put
these things together.
If you do these
two things today,
you'll be thinking
differently about your work
and about your life and
about your relationships.
And money back
guarantee, you're going
to be happier before
you go to bed tonight.
These are tips to better living.
And they're tips to making other
people live better as well.
I'm really grateful for this.
I'm really grateful
for the opportunity
to talk to you, as I just
mentioned a second ago.
And I would love to hear
how this works for you.
So give me feedback,
spread the ideas around,
write me an email at
Arthur.Brooks@AEI.org.
If it works for you, I
want to hear about it.
And I want to share that
with others as well.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MAX PAPPAS: Thank you, Arthur.
And if--
ARTHUR BROOKS: Thanks, Max.
MAX PAPPAS: --there
are any questions,
we have time for maybe one
or two quick questions.
I'll pass the mic.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
you think that there's something
fundamental to human dignity,
human flourishing that's
tied up with human labor.
And if so, what that
means for us in an economy
that's more
productive than ever,
but in which human labor is
an increasingly diminishing
component.
ARTHUR BROOKS: Yeah.
What a wonderful question.
What is the inherency of dignity
that comes from human labor?
I mean, there's really a
lot of philosophy on this.
I mean, the idea of
sanctified ordinary work
is a very common theme for
philosophers and theologians.
And what many people
have written about this,
just throughout the
ages, is that when
people have a sense of
their own self-worth,
it comes from
meaning and purpose.
Meaning and purpose
only comes when
you are serving others as
opposed to being served.
This Is the paradox of it.
When you're feeling
lousy about your life,
you want other people
to serve you more.
You want to stop feeling lousy?
Go serve other people more.
That paradoxical kind
of turning of the tables
actually is one of the
great secrets to happiness.
How can you do that
on a systematic basis,
is by seeing your work
as service to others
and making your work
into service to others.
That's how no matter
what you're doing--
whether you're coding or
you're building a wall
or you're running a think tank--
you can get greater joy from
it by remembering the people
that you are trying
to serve, whether it's
your coworkers or your clients.
That's really hugely important.
And this is a robust social
psychological finding
and a theological finding and a
philosophical finding as well.
Work brings happiness as long
as it is tied to purpose.
And purpose comes from
serving other people.
That's your job is to figure out
how to serve other people more.
So what does it mean
when people work less?
Let's not talk about
just service jobs
where people have less
robust human labor
or where people are even
cutting down on hours.
Let's talk about an economy
where fewer and fewer people
are needed in the workforce.
You've created almost
perfect storm, a formula
for unhappiness in doing that.
So this is connected to what
I've been talking about here,
right?
We basically say--
anytime you say look,
I don't think people should
have to take dead-end jobs,
you basically said
you're not going
to get dignity from work
because I've defined dignity out
of your work.
What an arrogant,
terrible thing to say.
Who treats their brothers
and sisters that way?
Everybody should
be able to work.
have dignified work
and get dignity from their work.
No such thing as a dead-end job.
That's critical.
But what we're basically doing
in our economy, of course,
is loading more
and more and more
of the value on the
workforce onto you
and onto me, the
people who are trying
to get more and more and
more and more productive
in the top 10% of the
income distribution.
That's what we're actually
trying to do, in which case,
we're basically saying
these things have
more dignity than other people.
What we should be
thinking about is
finding ways for other
people to earn their way
and not just in public policy,
in private industry as well.
And in doing that,
we'll have the formula
for passing on the blessings
that we take for granted.
For you, for me, the
one thing for you
to take away from
what I just said
is that meaning comes from work
when work provides service.
And service is all
about other people.
How am I serving my fellow
men and women more today?
I'm going to find
a way to do it.
On your way to work
in the mornings,
say I'm going to
serve more today.
I'm going to find a
better way to serve today.
And you go home happier with
a better appetite for dinner.
Thank you for that
wonderful question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
incentivize the private sector
to need the poor, especially
if it's less financially viable
than say serving the top 10%?
ARTHUR BROOKS: Yeah.
I'm asking the private sector to
be more creative in doing that,
because I think that
we're passing up
all sorts of opportunities.
And here's how I'd like to
ask you to think about it.
As an historic matter, every
prosperous and successful
society has made a major
inflection as prosperity
on the basis of energy and
of an energy source, right?
And sometimes it's
like finding oil.
But usually energy sources are
tied up in human ingenuity.
So the United States had a
major inflection of prosperity,
of productivity when we figured
out that universal education is
a really good thing.
Universal public education
is a great thing.
It's a huge public good.
It unlocked massive
amounts of human energy
and turn America into
a really great country.
It wasn't that long
ago, by the way.
It was like in the late
part of the 19th century was
when this started to happen.
It went along with
Industrial Revolution.
But it unlocked the
human capital revolution
in this country.
Energy sources are
a really big deal.
What we need to do to
be more creative about,
in the idea of part of the
private sector in particular--
we can talk about
manufacturing if you want.
But basically look,
this is Google.
This is the idea
part of the world.
And I'm in the American
Enterprise Institute, which
is an idea factory as well--
is finding better ways
to unlock the next wave
of human potential.
The most productive
areas of human potential
are going to be where it's
currently lying fallow,
not where it's already at its
highest degree of utilization,
right?
You've all heard the
old axiom that if you
want to get something
done, go to a busy person.
That is true as far as it goes.
But if you want
an army of people
who are going to
do new things, you
have to find people
who have free time.
And if you want to find ways to
radically inflect productivity
in this country, you
have to find the places
where we're simply
not asking people
to put their oar
in the water enough
and find ways to help
them get that done.
What is Google doing to
enhance the productivity
and the productive capacity
of people who are currently
behind the curtain
of how technology
can enhance effectively
their intelligence
and their productivity?
I mean, Google has made
me-- it's unbelievable
what this company has
done for me, by the way.
I'll tell you what it's done.
I mean, it's given me the
capacity at my fingertips,
with just me and devices.
It's given me the
imagination, creativity,
and the effective intelligence
far beyond the dreams
of Leonardo da Vinci.
That's what it's done in just
the last few years, right?
But why is it that the people
we're adding to in this way
are the people who
needed it the least?
And why do we keep finding
ways to make people at the top
more productive, more
creative, more prosperous?
Why are we not looking
for people who are not
at that particular place?
That's my challenge
to you, my friends.
That's what we should
be thinking about,
not just as social justice
warriors, but as people
who are trying to be
economically savvy, who
are looking for the next great
post-industrial revolution.
That's the answer that
we need to come up with.
And that's the answer we need
to come up with together.
MAX PAPPAS: Thank you, Arthur.
Thanks for everybody who came.
Thanks to everybody
who watched online.
Thanks for coming to Google.
ARTHUR BROOKS: Thanks, Max.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]